I have amazing quality camera now I've
been reading the comments and I've been
seeing some of you guys saying things
like Oh Felix is a terrible artist you
can't even draw excuse me I'll have you
know I am an amazing artist and I'm not
delusional so therefore we're gonna look
at other delusional artists not me real
artists I tried to draw sonic I try to
draw sonic from my memory it wasn't the
best okay but at least I tried
God forgive me
this dude thought his paintings were
good enough to get him into art school
in Vienna lol well goddamn Alex Jones
tries his hand at art I came up with
this if I seen it with symbol to
illustrate humankind transcending the
synthetic VR being pulled over our
collective soul incredible job Wow Alex
Jones what an artist I looked at flat
earthers profile out of curiosity and
Jesus Christ the head of John the
Baptist created by my group we can sell
it at the fair for at least a hundred at
least a hundred what in God's earth is
their hand Ron Harlequin portrait 500
dollars
only 500 my gosh that is
to you 500 for guaranteed nightmares
would you like it it's only 500 that's a
great price
you know what those hood used pastels to
capture the Battle of evil and innocence
I think you only captured evil I've said
this before and I'll say it again
stop being creative okay some people
just need to realize you have no talent
okay me however many talent especially
drawing like you can see I'm good at
drawing what is this the gentleman
applying for my 500 freelance book cover
art gig uses this image as an example of
his skill my god look so real she really
just look like a clown now that's
amazing what do you do you just added
blur and then just paint it on top you
know what I bet I can achieve this yeah
let's try it
three Gaussian blur get the ice back we
hit that and then just paint the cheeks
there you go what else the mouth as well
there you go $500 please thank you I am
an artist and I deserve to be paid oh my
god it's awesome if I could pay 500 to
do that only I didn't YouTube Jesus
Christ Ryan Reynolds in Deadpool 50
bucks you are looking at nine times
twelve colored pencil on heavy drawing
paper okay 50 bucks that's a great price
steampunk Indian [ __ ] loin cloth skirt
yes just what I've been looking for
finally something they took a bunch of
chips and just glued probably glue gun
into some I don't even know steampunk
100
five bucks Wow I would take first date
this is Indian squad loincloth adorned
with the computer parts there are sharp
edges so you should wear at your ovaries
I was just thinking about that it
probably cuts through Jesus Christ
wear it at your own risk you know what I
do like a challenge I don't know why
they should makes me laugh why are so
many people delusional mm Wow that's a
great piece I was gonna confetti in a
bag you know someone considered you know
this is like a fashion just put a high
price tag on anything and be like oh
look it's funny I bet you must be poor I
bet you don't have a mm bag of confetti
ready-made wall art it's a mattress
spring no no no no no it's art you put
it on the wall it's art okay you see
this chair you put it on the wall it's
up do me anything you can put on the
wall is art oh my god you want a
portrait like this send me a PM with
image and I will draw a sketch for 20
bucks created like this full-color 70 it
doesn't have an example of what the hell
color look like if you want more than
face send me message and we can talk
about the price I need to find this I
need to buy this
I'm the hottest rapper in the game right
now and that's a fact
it's a neem jail yes oh yeah I know you
know you're an artist when you sip tea
from a very common drug well using
that's of course the only definition of
an artist any other artist that existed
previously a Mac you know your
pretentious freaking butthole
oh yes the classic obviously they pay
$250 why did they pay them thank God
thank God for things like this Squidward
the first delusional artist
hey I mean that looks good come on it's
art you just don't understand it you
just don't understand our people ask me
why art and then I showed them this and
they kind of understand for a second
great goddamn this is so crazy
oh yes women in Orange bath smoking a
cigarette I get it this is so deep I
spent $20,000 pounds of benefits to look
like David Beckham wha how I can barely
tell the difference what did he spend
twenty thousand on the haircut I don't
want to know what he looked like before
20,000 pounds worth of Jesus Christ oh
my god they're retouching yes this is a
sponsor Wow
now you look like Fiona from Shrek
that's awesome only a quarter top yeah
well is that price okay I I'm curious if
I can replicate it just like so
get an idea what they did okay so first
of all they increase the saturation by
like increase saturation and they blur
the background it looked like they
increase the white point as well and
then they did such a poor job of
cropping out her hair that it looks like
one entity of things and then for some
reason they didn't made the eyes and
nose massive yeah they lifted the nose
at all I can't even make her that ugly
oh my god
I'm charged only a 1/5 of a dollar
please guys I am revenues real low I
would very just just pay me please
I'll retouch your photos this is a great
result
easy 2,600 jeez now I get why they're
called that she hates God it's so ugly
it just looks it's bad but this is the
the perfect example I was talking about
with fashion it's like just put a high
price tag on it and people will buy it
that's all you need to do a bit you
can't afford to look homeless yeah I get
it some items are like well-designed and
I know a lot of people have problems
with holes in items being like oh you
could use make a knight to me this is
just ugly it's as ugly OSHA internal
simulator 1 I'm downloading this right
now my school actually paid for this wow
it looks so beautiful handmade Mongolian
battle mash
estimated to be from the 11th century
prize from 700 mm this looks like
someone's kid would bring home from
kindergarten and you would immediately
throw it in the trash and punch the
child for wasting human space little tat
I did contact me for prices rates go
from 150 to a thousand thousand that's a
great price who made this I want it 100
200 wanna stick wow what a wonderful
painting
I sure wonder what the prize is it must
be just a couple thousand a thousand
five hundred what I'm buying it right oh
okay everyone please you're bent how
much you think this is priced let me
know in the comments down below that's
right you all guessed it right twenty
thousand max of steel you know I wasn't
gonna buy this before when it was five
hundred and fifty but now it's four
hundred and seventy five my god reptile
baby reptile baby recreated by myself
serious inquiries only you know what I'm
gonna buy myself a reptile baby I have
40 bucks to spare and I'm you know I
don't care what haters are saying I'm
treating myself with a reptile baby
thank you guys for watching these
dilutional artists with me and as of
course me not delusional artist me
phenomenal artist as you can tell by my
art which I'm now gonna sell for the
great price of two thousand it's up on
eBay so you can buy it for the low price
of very little smash like subscribe
remember check out merch oh it's a
little cold in here oh what's that
epic merch last day today boy last day
it's now or never check out the merch
buy what you never played to purr
simulator you know it's fun right I'm
not supposed to give my opinion but give
it a try and then you can tell me if
it's good or not not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]